buenas tardes es una buena noticia para
el fundador de wikileaks julian assange
a quien la justicia británica hoy le ha
permitido apelar ante la corte suprema
británica un fallo previo de diciembre
de 2021 que abría la posibilidad para
ser extraditado a los estados unidos
durante la audiencia la prometida de
assange estela maurice con quien tuvo
dos hijos cuando estaba asilado en la
embajada de ecuador aquí en londres ha
celebrado este fallo ha dicho que
assange ha ganado pero ha lamentado
además que mientras este proceso
judicial avanza aquí en el reino unido-
assange siga preso en la cárcel de
máxima seguridad de belmarsh aquí en
londres donde su salud física y mental
continúa deteriorándose si assange es
extraditado a eeuu debe responder por al
menos 17 delitos entre ellos espionaje
lo que le daría si es condenado una pena
de más de 175 años de cárcel hablamos de
eso precisamente luisa de los escenarios
posibles para julian assange
este es un proceso judicial que puede
tardar incluso años lo que sigue a
partir de este día es que la justicia de
assange cuenta con dos semanas para
presentar ante la corte suprema
británica los argumentos de por qué no
debe ser extraditado a eeuu y porque ese
proceso judicial debe continuar aquí en
los tribunales británicos después en
algunos meses la corte suprema
establecerá si continuará o no con este
proceso judicial pero lo cierto es que
mientras avanza toda esta audiencia
estos procesos judiciales de assange
aquí en el reino unido- y todavía
continúa el debate sobre si a sánchez
periodista o hacker los medios de
comunicación más prestigiosos del mundo
organizaciones en defensa de la libertad
de expresión y la democracia han
alertado que si assange es extraditado a
los estados unidos
entonces sentaría un precedente muy
peligroso para el futuro del periodismo
y la libertad de información